and and what about friends never said
i oppose frackie he'll be against it
very soon because his party
is totally against fracking natural gas
extraction by way of hydraulic
fracturing
or fracking may not have been the top
issue on the minds of most voters coming
into this election season
but in the final weeks of the campaign
they've witnessed a fracas
over fracking you yourself said on
multiple occasions when you were running
for president
that you would ban fracking joe biden
will not
ban fracking that is a fact so
why so much talk of fracking because
pennsylvania is the biggest swing state
after florida
and fracking could be the key to the
keystone state
in 2016 trump won the state by running
up the score
in blue-collar counties like those
around pittsburgh
to all the people of pennsylvania here
this warning
if biden's elected he will wipe out your
energy
industry i am not not
not banning fracking period pittsburgh
and its surrounding counties used to be
united in a kind of
iron triangle of steel labor unions and
democratic politics
but steel and coal entered a long
decline then
fracking brought new jobs income and
hope to counties outside of pittsburgh
which have become more republican while
pittsburgh has turned to tech
and remained solidly democrat when the
fracking boom took off in pennsylvania
so did employment jobs and two major
components of oil and gas extraction
grew four-fold
what really made our company grow was
when we started to support the oil and
gas industry
paul bergad owns a small business that
manufactures foam products
used by the fracking industry fairgod
lives and works in
armstrong county just northeast of
pittsburgh in an area where we had
people
leaving in mass exodus it's the oil and
gas that's bringing people back
it is the new steel mill everybody knows
somebody that's in
that industry but in recent years the
u.s fracking industry has essentially
become a victim of its own success
pumping so much gas that excess supply
has kept
prices depressed and here that's led to
less jobs and fracking according to data
by the u.s commerce department
by late 2019 employment in the two big
components of pennsylvania's oil and gas
sector
had fallen by about 26 percent if we
lose that oil and gas industry that is
what pays the overhead is what pays
the labor and when you begin to take
something like that away the business
may not be profitable enough to survive
i see us reverting back to a desperate
situation that we were before we had the
industry here in western pennsylvania
jan mcintyre works as a consultant for
the fracking industry
she lives and works in washington county
south of pittsburgh
the difference between us being
gainfully employed
or not employed my husband doesn't have
a degree to fall back on
beargat and mcintyre say they both voted
for trump last time
and plan to do so again one reason on
the issue of fracking
they say they don't trust biden and the
democrats
no more no no fracking after a march
democratic debate
biden's campaign clarified that his
position proposes a ban
only on new fracking on federal
while people in mcintyre's community
make their living from the drilling
economy
a short distance away a growing number
of workers are part of the coding
economy
in pittsburgh at companies like google
tesla
and duolingo high-tech jobs now account
for roughly 24
of the workforce in and around the city
according to the pittsburgh technology
council
we have a lot of great universities and
big tech companies but also
a strong heritage of steel working and
factory working in middle class
todd medema moved from california to
pittsburgh about 10 years ago to study
at carnegie mellon university
after graduating he stayed to work for
uber's self-driving vehicle program
minima recently switched to another
high-tech transportation company so
google moving to pittsburgh back in in
2005 2006
really kicked off a flywheel effect
where instead of everyone leaving
pittsburgh they would stay start new
companies
and now we have a thriving startup scene
multiple incubators
most of these tech workers hold
bachelors or advanced degrees
these types of voters have been swinging
away from the gop
for the 2020 presidential election my
top issue is the environment
especially having a strong plan to
address climate change
opponents of fracking say it prolongs
the country's reliance on fossil fuels
it's also become controversial because
of chemicals used in the process that
could taint water supplies if not
handled properly
despite fracking's downsides minimus
says he understands his fellow
pennsylvanians fears about losing jobs
the people who work on fracking are
are honest hard-working americans and i
really have no
fault with them if you really want
good jobs you'll vote for biden because
he has a plan to
make the american economy innovative and
relevant
going forward not just for today's
fossil fuel industry
but voters like barad are not convinced
when they talk about
the new jobs that will come with solar
with
windmills the other energies there's
nothing there
that says for sure that is going to
happen
on election day it could all come down
to what happens in western pennsylvania
eight days from now we're going to win
the commonwealth of pennsylvania
biden hopes to hold on to progressives
while peeling off some of the
pro-fracking voters who went for trump
last time
and trump needs more pro-fracking
blue-collar workers from this area
casting ballots for him than did in
2016.
two groups so geographically close
yet politically so far away
[Music]
you